j'ai toujours célibataire
vous n'êtes pas mariée
non je suis pas marié voilà vous êtes
toujours quelque part disponible pour le
mariage exactement
donc on va savoir ce que vous êtes prêts
à faire par amour comme ça toutes les
filles pourront juger si vous êtes un
bon mari on va faire une interview par
amour
est-ce que par amour vous arrêteriez de
faire votre métier non
parce que j'ai de la personnalité arrête
tes conneries
mandat par amour je fais n'importe quoi
mais l'amour passe avant tout par amour
je renonce à ma mon métier je me fais
refaire là ouais je me teins envers sa
c6 du sort avec quelques
par amour titoff est ce que vous
arrêteriez de vous droguez
mais je sais déjà fait en fait oui c'est
déjà fait là j'ai arrêté j'ai dit plus
que plus qu'à la noël en famille
sinon le reste de l'année c'est fini a
caché le corps de la personne qu'elle
vient de tuer ou
non le nom âge là dénonce d'abord
jade et nous lui gaz ubs a pris à
moquette
est ce que par amour vous accepteriez
qu'elle a un amant
si c'est un bon copain huawei
alors voir poser des questions avoue
bernard parce que moi je trouve que
quand les corps n'ont plus rien à se
dire je suis pas la séparation des corps
des liens
ci ne
s que par amour si tôt vous seriez prêt
à fréquenter des clubs échangistes
jeu c'est plutôt démodé je trouve un les
ya plus que les vieux mec de la télé
les serveurs mais qui ne
chérit oui on m'a passé un petit billet
là
je suis une personne qui a marqué passe
de l'autre côté de la guerre des étoiles
voilà